hi i'm ria today a friend is challenging
me to take a popular food and make it
fancy today's guest is aldi let's see
what i'm making fancy today hello best
friend i love the mcdonald's big mac and
their fries i think they're incredible i
don't eat it very often but when i do
it's always nice so
i don't know how you're gonna be able to
make them fancy but if there's anybody
that can make the big mac and the fries
fancy
it's yuri because you're my best friend
and that's what best friends do they
believe in each other they challenge
each other and i'm excited to see what
you make
mcdonald's big mac and french fries i've
had french fries but i've never had
big mac i like hamburgers just seeing
package big mac doesn't look like big
wow look nice though looks very rich and
a lot
kind of sad looking out there does it
have pickles too yeah there is a pickles
oh
it's not bad in the past i always add
neutralizing ingredients but i think i
should add a more beefy component and
i'm not sure how i'm going to
incorporate this with soggy lettuce it's
not fancy
i think they have one of the best french
fries albie has made giant burgers for
his show make it back so it's natural he
chose big mac he made a giant but i have
to make fancy this is
i feel like one of the most difficult
thing
to make it fancy because it's one
complete meal changing this is very hard
but i want to surprise albin i have some
great ideas and i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got short ribs
mushrooms grilled cheese butter eggs
beaks parsley carrots celery thyme
cabbage onion garlic and heavy cream
from the pantry i got tomato paste lemon
bay leaves olive oil salt flour beef
stock canola oil brown sugar red wine
and vodka double alcohol all right let's
get started
make it fancy
[Music]
okay so we have short ribs hot dry weeds
paper towel sprinkle some salts in both
sides you want to sprinkle salt in high
it will cover evenly and heating up some
oil about two tablespoons this is the
first time we use instant on this show i
don't have instant at home but it's very
convenient it usually takes about four
hours what i'm making but if you use
instant pot you can make it about 45
minutes but from future it mean like we
already in the future
so i am adding show ribs using saute
mode brown the beef both sides about two
to three minutes beef is nicely browned
saute onions
celery and carrots
sprinkle some salt so it cooks faster
and also seasoning peppers cook until
vegetable is a little bit softened raise
the brown beets bottoms apart from
b that is the flavor comes from so don't
wipe it out from paper towel or anything
are you familiar
oh it's this way so his name is ronald i
thought he was donald like uh the duck
veggies uh cooked and softened add
garlic and the thyme a lot of people
want to put garlic before
adding anything else but garlic tended
to burn quickly so you want to add
garlic later cook until garlic is
fragrant about one to two minutes two
tablespoons tomato paste cook until
tomato paste change the color to dark
deep red one tablespoon of brown sugar
one cup of beef stock
one cup of red wine no i love this smell
like red wine and garlic i'm putting
back beef i sauteed earlier this juice
don't discard this adds a lot of flavor
it's a liquid gold so you want to make
sure beef is submerged in this braising
liquid and i think it's not enough so
i'm gonna just add more wine
the bay leaves put the lid you want to
press pressure cook mold and set the
timer for 45 minutes while it's cooking
let's move on to next step 2 cup of
heavy cream mcdonald's french fries i
don't like drive through in general i
don't like shouting at the machine i
like you my interaction so it is very
thick kind of pale yellow and i'm going
to strain this and press all the wicket
out process potato in a food mill so i
learned this trick from my coworker five
on the right side and one on the left
side so it doesn't stop food milk helps
french fries into the texture i want if
you don't have a food meal you can use
potato ricer looks good chill this in
the fridge about 15 minutes potato is
chilled and separated pretty nicely it's
almost look like a cauliflower rice
it's not good for you and i'm adding
this into
flour add salt
and toss
two tablespoons of butter incorporate
into the flour and the french fry
mixture you kind of want to make butter
into a small bit almost like a pea side
but it's well incorporated in the flour
and one tablespoon of bokeh i recommend
put
vodka in the freezer sprinkle
ice water into the flour mixture a
little by little you need a little bit
make sure everything is incorporated
dough came together covered with plastic
make it a little bit flattened so it's
easier to roll i'm going to put in a
refrigerator for 30 minutes i have
cabbage leaves blanch them two to three
minutes until cabbage is a little bit
soft not crunchy soak them in ice water
so it will stop cooking cheese cabbage
almost look like a fake food remove the
core chop
roughly i want to keep four nice looking
leaves set this aside until i'm going to
use next time burger time gonna do some
operation take off buns scrape
soggy lettuce and pickle cheese it's
perfectly brown though i'm gonna set
this aside rough chop the burger put in
a bowl has a different kind of
resistance meat
bouncy definitely not juicy and i'm
adding back this
this thing
half cup of gruyere cheese because it
has a very sharp cheese flavor basically
this episode i'm doing everything
opposite of past episodes i'm adding
more flavor no neutralizing a quarter
cup of cream fresh tablespoon of chopped
parsley one teaspoon of lemon juice it
is well mixed set aside bake this bread
at 350 degrees about 15 to 20 minutes
until the bun is completely dried out
heat up some olive oil add two leeks
just the white part no green part green
part is a little too hard to eat so you
want to use it for stocks sprinkle some
salt and saute until soft leeks are
cooked i have three different kinds of
mushrooms maitake
king trumpet and baby bella i want to
use three different mushrooms because it
will give different texture and flavor
especially king trump that has like very
nice meaty bites
a little bit more oil and salt
wait do they have coffee meals in japan
we do have happy meals in japan and i
think one of the
toys come with it was tea white stuffed
animals and i bought it
i think i was high school actually i
might have it in my parents house it was
monkey mushroom is cooked so i'm adding
three cloves of chopped garlic and one
teaspoon of thyme cook until fragrant
right smells great remove this from the
heat i'm adding into a bowl add chopped
cabbage big mac filling soggy lettuce
onions thousand iron dressing and
pickles the reason i chose cabbage was i
want to balance out saltiness of the
lettuce with crunchy cabbage beautiful
keep this in the fridge until ready to
use this it's the short ribs i cooked in
an instant pot take out this kind of
beef stew it's my favorite kind of food
that's like a good deal right there
right yeah
there's no mcdonald's in it though
shred beef look how tender i put
shredded beef in the bowl
instantly it's great maybe i should get
one if you don't have instant pot you
can definitely
make this in a cast iron pot and cook in
the oven but it will take longer so if
you don't want to use red wine you can
just use beef stock but i don't think
you have that rich flavor cover shredded
beef with breathing liquid to prevent
beef is drying out so make sure remove
the bay leaf because you cannot eat it
and i have some glazing liquid leftover
but i want to use for something else
okay so i have a lot of components so
let's recap i have blanched cabbage
leaves mushroom and leek stuffing
shredded beef and big mac cheese filling
i've got this glass bowl lined with
plastic put cabbage leaves stem side
down and the leaf side is kind of
hanging add half of this mushroom leek
mixture press it down
you can also see the pickles right here
it's great to see you again add shredded
beef well this is everything i
love kind of blessing now again
big mac burger cheese mixture
pressing done
and add rest of the mushroom mix i'm
arranging cabbage leaf so the stuffing
doesn't exposed seal the bottom with
cabbage and clothes the dome
covered with
plastic so it doesn't dry out chill this
in the refrigerator about 30 minutes
this seeds the buns i toasted earlier it
is
it's hard break
it's a little bit little piece the power
is already a little dry side but we
toast it so we can make breadcrumbs
add in uh a food processor
i'm going to set aside and move on to
the next step i have two tablespoons of
butter melt this in the pot and one cup
of mushroom it's the same mushroom i
used earlier saute them until softened
one crushed clove of garlic and one
teaspoon of thyme and season with salt
add in one cup of beef stock short ribs
braising liquid one cup increasing the
heat quarter cup of bread crumb usually
you thicken gravy with flour but i'm
using bread crumbs from big mac buns
this is kind of trick ingredient
he's in new york and i'm like but you
know we text each other sometimes we are
good friends we are making videos for
our new channel called about to eat this
is a logo check it out and subscribe
bring this to a boil and simmer until
gravy thickens so it seems like a nice
thickness and now i'm going to strain
kind of stir to make sure all the
liquids it's coming through adding
strained gravy back into a frying pan
and heat over medium high heat once it's
simmered i'm adding butter
looks good it's nice and thick set this
aside and move on to next step pie dough
with french fries this was chilling in
the refrigerator sprinkle some flour so
it doesn't stick on the surface sprinkle
on top a little bit rolling pink
and constantly adding flour so it
doesn't stick doesn't smell like french
fry anymore and keep rotating so you can
roll like a round shape in the 80s
mcdonald's
oh how did it go
that's why we don't see
pizza in mcdonald's i'm going to cut
with a knife brush off the excess flour
on top and transfer to a baking sheet
pan using fork dock this pie doll so it
doesn't shrink and using a pastry brush
brush egg wash
loom only set this aside for now i have
half pastry sprinkle some flour and roll
unwrap the plastic part
a mold cabbage dome dub this with some
paper towel cover cabbage stone with
puff pastry and use your hands and
tuck it in
use the same glass bowl and
cut excess dough
use
your thumb
and crimp like you cream pie doll you
want to brush egg wash when you bake the
pie it will give nice shine you just
want to score so you don't want to cut
through and in between line i'm going to
make another line use piping tip cut
leftover pastry and
cut out
use
both sides and make look like a donut
and put donut on top just the dough part
so the steam escape and it doesn't too
puffy cover with egg wash and put one
more donut and finish with
egg wash
a little bit more lime
sprinkle some
sesame seeds sesame seeds kind of adds
nice accent and they kind of look like
the big mac bun i'm going to put this in
the refrigerator and chill about 30
minutes and bake this 425 for 15 minutes
so it will get nice brown color reduce
the heat to 350 and bake another 45
minutes so everything cooks through so
my mcdonald's petit beer is baked and
cooled and i'm going to put in a plate
here it's the gravy and we are done
[Music]
mcdonald's big mac french fry petty beer
very fancy this is something you cannot
get from drive through let's see what
alvin thinks
hello best friend hi this may be the
most challenging thing i'm sorry that i
put so much pressure on you so i
actually never had a big mug before
really the next time
i'm in la i'm going to take you out to
dinner and i'm gonna buy you a big mac
what is that wait there's a name for
this is it a big mac pativier yes i want
to see what's inside i'm mind blown
right now ree
oh
wow look at those layers this looks like
something you could order at a
restaurant thank you i'm sorry you
cannot eat it i'll pretend i'll eat with
you imaginary pity beer
oh yeah
so many textures in there well honestly
that that looks really legitimately a
really great interpretation of a big mac
so alvin did i make mcdonald's fancy
best friend
i think you 100
made mcdonald's
fancy thank you best friend all right so
alvin we have one last things to do yes
we do three two one
[Music]
you